plus les heures passent plus le bilan
fait mal au coeur ce soir j'ai à coeur
vraiment de nous rendre utiles tous
ensemble pour les centaines de personnes
qui vivent un cauchemar depuis la nuit
de vendredi à samedi
ce n'est pas terminé puisque y encore
des recherches en cours avec de nombreux
disparus
et pour vous rendre compte de l'horreur
que vivent les habitants je vous propose
de regarder un avant/après qui a offert
froid dans le dos regardez bien cette
avant après juste après on recevra
gilbert habitants de saint martin
vésubie qui témoignera de l'enfer vécu
encore maintenant dans son village
c'est le plus touché par la tempête
regardez ce avant après vraiment c'est
ouf
regarde le torrent de montagne a ravagé
l'arrière-pays fois saint-martin de
vésubie était entouré d'un écrin de
verdure
il n'en restera qu'un la violence de
l'eau à tailler la montagne emporté les
maisons les plus proches de son nom les
éboulements ont continué rien n'est
stabilisé cette petite résidence a pris
de plein fouet la montée des eaux
elle a fini par s'effondrer ses deux
occupants ont été emportés ils sont
disparus plusieurs centaines de maisons
ont été détruites ou sont désormais
inhabitable
comme ce chalet qui sur fond maintenant
le torrent alors qu'ils étaient hier
encore à plusieurs dizaines de mètres du
cours d'eau voici la station service
avant la catastrophe
elle a disparu sous les yeux de notre
journal à la place un bout de route
effondrée alors je voudrais remercier
gilbert daon d'être avec nos habitants
de saint martin vésubie visage le
village le plus touché par la tempête
alex
merci infiniment d'être avec nous marc
ferro déjà je sais que vous êtes encore
extrêmement touchée déjà comment vous
allez parce que depuis quelques jours
c'est vrai que vous dormez plus vous
voilà parlant depuis depuis vendredi
c'est la seule la catastrophe
on a plus de villages c'est on se plie
en ce clou allez on se fait plus c'est
vraiment une très très grosse
catastrophe près de 70 maisons et
endommagé ou complètement détruit
complètement détruite il ya plus
personne n'y a plus rien
on a plus de vous n'arrêtez pas depuis
ce week-end bien sûr pour aider un
ornais dont fait on fait tout ce qu'on
peut en faire manger on fait on aide
pour tout ce qui est secours les
pompiers la protection civile
tout le monde peut on faire manger on
faire manger pour alors on va revenir
sur le récit de dames jeudi dernier
météo france prévoyait un épisode
tempétueux dans les alpes maritimes
est ce que vous attendiez à une si
grande violence comment ça s'est passé
quelques heures avant vous disais voilà
si vous n'étiez pas aussi inquiet que ce
que ce qui s'est passé
ah non on n'était pas inquiet parce que
la d alerte on en a eu et on en a eu un
honneur encore mais on pensait pas un
on a toujours entendu les alertes ne
vous avez très bien en bon ça nous passe
au dessus vous étiez préparé quand même
pas de ma non pas du tout pas du tout
plein on a dû aller retour au jeu mais à
les retoucher toi mais là on a eu des
plus et des pluies
mais comme ça c'était c'est
catastrophique
vient la soirée de vendredi sur et
cauchemardesque selon vous quel comment
ça se passe qu'est ce qu'est ce qui se
passe vraiment minute par minute
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous êtes à la
maison où vous avez en face un ballon
qui fait 10 m 15 m et d'un coup ils ont
fait pratiquement 200 vous avez tout ou
triangle après vous avez les voisins qui
mène à la maison parce que moi j'ai la
maison entre guillemets un peu plus
retirés qui va pas tarder à tomber je
pense mais dont le que j'ai recueilli
des personnes des les voisins sont venus
à la maison et on entendait ce bruit ce
bruit sourd ce bruit sourd c'était et
depuis depuis vendredi
vous voyez bien c'est depuis depuis
vendredi plus personne dort plus
personne
hélas la nuit de vendredi à samedi
les minutes sont des heures impossibles
de fermer l'oeil bien entendu impossible
vous avez perpétue la pire nuit de votre
vie vous dit même que vous êtes sentis
pris au piège
on n'était plus au pérou et en est pris
au pire je post journée on est sur le
sur un flanc on est à caméra les cinq
kilomètres de la maison un peu plus haut
que la en moi vous vous réfugiez bon
parce qu'il paraît que votre métier de
maître maison et est inaccessible voilà
maintenant la maison est inaccessible
ton à tout le monde a été évacué et on
s'est réfugié sur un dans un pré après
la protection civile est venue nous
pendre nous emmener sur le sur la place
du village
il a vous êtes vous dormez ou faites
vous êtes avait après chacun chez
l'habitant
les hôtels ont été
heureusement on a tous les hôtes et 20
les hôtels ce qui reste on a deux deux
hôtels à saint-martin et après aller
la solidarité c'est incroyable justement
à propos de solidarité il faut dire
qu'il ya des appels aux dons qui ont été
faits par le secours populaire et la
croix-rouge faire attention parce qu'à
des cagnottes qui commence à se monter
ici ou là qui sont pas des vrais
cagnotte
donc vraiment aller sur des sites
vraiment très certifié il ya également
de quelque chose que je trouve vraiment
bien c'est plusieurs villes ont ouvert
des points de collecte pour aider des
gens comme vous annie sié le palais
nikaïa à menton le palais de l'europe et
les autres villes comme grace mandelieu
vance
renseignez vous auprès de vos
municipalité parce qu'effectivement il
ya des endroits où on récolte à la fois
de la nourriture des vêtements du lait
pour les bébés ferrat etc et il ya aussi
le département des alpes-maritimes qui a
annoncé le déblocage d'un fonds de 1500
euros par foyer pour venir en aide à des
gens comme vous et là il faut tout
simplement appeler un numéro vert qui
est le 0 805 0 16 666 ça c'est pour les
gens qui peuvent essayer de récupérer au
moins mais 500 euros dead en urgence
sous peu alors alors c'est vrai que là
les aides se met en place mais c'est
c'est un tel boulot c'est assez
incroyable gilbert fait aussi partie de
la mairie alors les efforts des pompiers
ils ont été énormes énorme non mais une
fois de plus encore bravo où
malheureusement ils sont toujours en
train de trouver des corps on trouve
tous les jours tous les jours tous les
jours on trouve des clubs
bien souvent on se fait perdu des amis
oui ouais n'est pas un des pompiers d'un
notamment des jeunes pompiers et
j'habitais un tout ce que vous vous
dites aujourd'hui dans le village est ce
qu'on se dit on se dit bonjour le jour
d'essayer de 2 en bus le jour le jour
mais en
on va tout faire pour reconstruire on
veut redémarrer on veut pas partir on
veut toutes les personnes que moi non on
est pratiquement tous nés là haut dont
le tombeur rester là-haut et puis bon et
il ya tous ces gens là tous ces artisans
ces commerçants
bien sûr ils ont tout perdu tout perdu
c'est comme ça c'est qu'on n'a pas
d'autre mot sinon il n'y a pas d'autre
mot que je marque alors oui j'ai envie
parce qu'il faut bien se rendre compte
de hordes en plus de la perte financière
c'est aussi une vie qui s'efface et mon
père les souvenirs et surtout les livres
les jouets des enfants tout ce qui
faisait une vie g et construit qui
s'efface y est c'est pas que de l'argent
c'est aussi maintenant ce qu'il ya de
l'argent c'est il ya tous les commodity
à les souvenirs il ya tout cela qui est
terrible après bon et nous ça va on n'a
pas à mais ceux qui ont perdu des êtres
chers
c'est pour eux pour eux ce que le
catastrophique due qu'à une chose
positive dans ce marasme
si la solidarité la solidarité parce
qu'on voit du des gens arriver du
département du département n'a dé tous
les jours tous les jours on est sur la
place où on en récolte en récolte de
l'eau de l'eau beaucoup d'eau je te
l'eau n'est pas potable
on a les plombiers toutes ont tout fait
pour nous emmener des points d'eau sur
la place pour avoir de l'eau pour le
seul avait pour les toilettes ainsi de
suite et après on a les pactes on
distribue l'autre comme ça alors vous
savez on avait envie de se mobiliser
voilà pour pour vous essayer de faire ce
qu'on peut on a décidé de vous soutenir
avec des produits de première nécessité
pour plusieurs familles des villages
impactés par la tempête alex ce soir on
appeler notre partenaire les magasins
but voilà et nous avons décidé d'offrir
25000 euros damende blement
d'électroménager aussi de l'après midi
avec toulouse conserve un matelas
canapés tables fauteuils mais également
du gru et petit électroménager
réfrigérateur gazinière micro-ondes
machine à café je tenais vraiment alors
je vous le dis parce que sinon on a des
partenaires voilà c'est notre partenaire
qui nous a dit qu'il voulait le faire et
il nous a suivis tout particulièrement
la direction des magasins but
jessica teixeira empereur caroline
saint-aubin sophie darmon et toutes les
équipes des magasins ils ont été
formidables
ça vient de la situation donc bravo est
parce qu ils ont ils nous ont tout de
suite dit me quand on leur a demandé
voilà deux de l'aide est donc merci à
eux alors ça va sévèrement ces voix là
on a on essaie de faire le maximum et il
faut vraiment essayer de vous aider et
que tout le monde se mobilisent parce
que j'espère que c'est un vrai drame
j'espère que ce sera la glose tu vas
faire démarrer le bon on veut remonter
notre nuage je sais qu'éric ciotti avait
la vue voilée c'est un enfant du village
mais sait on le soutient à fond si son
initiative et voilà bon si tu vois là on
essaie de faire quelque chose merci ben
jeu au nom de l' de notre maire monsieur
yvan montée de tous les habitants de
saint martin vésubie
je tiens à vous remercier lambersart ya
vraiment on aimerait faire plus et on
pense très très fort à vous chaque
seconde cachée de mercy gilbert
qui sait